point des gens qui depuis plus d'un mois
sont en train de parler d'une revue qui
est en kiosque depuis 24 heures 48
heures donc bernard henri lévy a estimé
que j'étais jacques doriot j'adore jouer
quand même quelqu'un qui a porté
l'uniforme nazi sur le front russe qui
était fasciste
j'ai eu il ya un délire complet de la
part de tous ses journaux discussions
finalement propriété de de même famille
de milliardaires qui sont d'ailleurs
subventionnés par les impôts de l'état
voilà donc des gens qui nous ont dit que
cette revue était remplie nationaux
souverainistes de fasciste et terrasses
a fait 48 heures qu'on peut la voir
et depuis 16h depuis deux jours depuis
16 heures il y a deux jours j'irai 500
points de vente sont privés de la revue
parce que tout le monde se jette dessus
donc voilà des gens qui parlent d'un
film qu'ils n'ont pas vu qui parle d'un
vin qui n'ont pas bu qui parle de livres
qu'ils n'ont pas lui qui parle d'une
revue qui n'ont pas encore eu entre les
mains
tout ça ce sont bien les méthodes de la
presse qui effectivement mans comme un
seul homme et ça c'est un peu ce qui les
caractérise donc oui elle dit des
bêtises et comme le monde est le premier
à dire des bêtises libération s'empresse
de lendemains de dire la même bêtise et
le surlendemain de france inter fait de
même et c'est donc plutôt la preuve que
ces gens là sont de connivence me dise
pas la vérité alors on s'excuse avoir
repris ses bêtises et on est absolument
ravie de vous accueillir sur un
entretien longue durée pour que vous
puissiez rétablir votre vérité parce que
évidemment c'est important de dire cette
phrase de philippe bilger ne fait pas
partie des contributeurs non plus si
vous voulez qu'on reprenne les choses
les unes après les autres
philippe bilger le minime de beaucoup
philippiques jamais et on l'a pas
approcher ne nous a pas approchés il ne
fait pas partie du comité d'action il
n'a pas donné de texte il ne fait pas
partie de l'équipe donc cette partie
effectivement dit comment expliquer
justement ces fausses d'information
effectivement qu'on a vraiment pu lire
dans des presses quand même sérieuses
qui sont supposés vérifier les
informations un journal le monde
effectivement est supposé quand même
vérifier l'information comment vous vous
l'expliquer et un manque justement de
vérification des sources où il ya une
volonté peut-être de mal présenter votre
projet dois-je vraiment sérieusement que
le monde était un jour l'un de ces
questions en tout cas il est présenté
comme tel oui présenté par les journaux
comme un journal sérieux mais comme
lille se sont tous copains et coquins
évidemment le monde
parce qu'on l'a journal de référence
mais ça passe pour un journal de
référence pour les journalistes qui eux
mêmes sont entre les mains de quelques
milliardaires qui en plus de sa demande
de l'argent du contribuable pour pouvoir
faire une propagande éhontée depuis une
vingtaine d'années donc ça fait bien
longtemps que je ne lis plus les
journaux là ou alors juste pour savoir
quel est le ton de la propagande mais
non le monde n'est pas sérieux enfin le
monde dit n'importe quoi les propos vous
avez repris en pensant que le monde et
est un journal de référence vous font
dire effectivement les bêtises que ces
gens là disent même s'allonge nous
n'avons jamais été des nationaux
souverainiste nous n'avons jamais été si
nous sommes par exemple jamais sollicité
philippe bilger que j'aime beaucoup de
les ornements mais ce sont de fausses
informations